hello viewer happy fourth I don't know
why I'm that maybe you call it
independence they don't know why I'm
dancing like this I'm going to zag when
you expect me to Zig because notice my
pasty white thigh we're going to be
talking about black history I'm here
with David Barton of wall builders and
the all-powerful sorcerer and he called
him Tim and today we'll be talking
specifically about black history and I
think important to first off let me gets
out of the way three white guys talking
about black history we get it let's move
on from that what do you think it is
that most people get wrong about black
history I almost think they don't know
much about it then there's a few
stereotypical names they'll get they'll
get MLK to get Harriet Tubman that let
me get Sojourner Truth I mean for Jos
Frederick Douglass but past that the
route and and those are really good
people people say I think I can sit as a
Canadian we really look yep MLK Rosa
Parks yeah Harriet Tubman and outside of
that not a whole lot yeah there is so
much more and that's where the story
gets rich and deep as you do a lot of
biographical history you find that the
first double spy in American history was
a black American you find that we have
an entire Midwestern state whose
nickname is based on a black American
you find that what are the great heroes
in the battle for Bunker Hill famous
battle was a black America I mean
there's so many of these guys that have
done so much stuff that we don't study
today that if we studied them we'd go oh
my gosh there is so much I thought we
were efficient to get four or five good
names out of history for black you know
there's there's I think the
mischaracterization is that before the
Civil War we think of black Americans as
being victims yeah right and that's
really their history right because we're
at least not working alongside white
America right because you know they're
only they're only existence in America
was largely slaves and this is where
there's so much misconception because
there were so many early American heroes
who were blacks and so then we would ask
question then then why don't we know any
of the early heroes or are we just
making this up right and then this is a
lot larger to say in academia that's
because it's white and men who write
American history and they've margins
sure but you made a point to that I
think it is really key if I take the
Scout right here this is a famous
painting from the American Founding it
is a black preacher Lemuel Haynes we
actually this is
his stuff right here he is the first
black man this is actually his Bible he
was a preacher and this is his Bible
with his mother was nameless that
determined which which tribe you were in
and Harry Potter so there was the Hat I
don't think that was a hat way off okay
yeah I mean to watch the series again so
he's the this is his Bible literally I
mean this this white guy and and these
are sermons he preached he's the first
black man to have a sermon printed in
America he was a soldier in the American
Revolution what's interesting about it
is if you will look at this picture
right here yeah that's a black guy
that's a white congregations right and
that was not at all uncommon have black
preachers of white congregations but
what we get is we get a southern view of
black history there's a northern view
where blacks are freed that never was
the time in Massachusetts history when
blacks could not vote there's a middle
colony view where they're oppressed but
there are some abolition going on and
there's a southern view which is full
oppression what we get a heavy dose of
in America there's a southern view of
black history not a northern view and
there's so many heroes and so much
wholesome stuff that people do not know
what is particularly they don't know the
northern version of black which evens
that end so one of the books we have is
from a historian William now who wrote
about all of the black heroes from
earlier America so even before Frederick
Douglass there were black heroes today
people have never heard of those black
heroes this was from the American
Revolution so and it's time well I don't
want to read the title yeah it's the
color pager to the America revolution
now it seems a little insensitive it's
the African American patriots and or
Patriots of color there is okay see but
this was actually a Amex together than
an original printing of mine come not
here but maybe so he was actually a
black historian writing about these guys
ready and and this was not an uncommon
thing we have several history books
Blackie was Marana number Tom in thick
history but we're not talking a little
pamphlet just one or two guys we're
talking thick history books with dozens
and hundreds of black heroes very well
known names the question arises then why
don't we know those names today and this
is where let me jump over here because
now you have a lot of books here so so
this series was done by probably one of
our least favorite presidents Woodrow
Wilson oh if we took a guess we found
five or ten names out there and Woodrow
Wilson you know when Glenn Beck used to
get out his chalkboard
he was always his name was written at
the top yes he was the devil of all well
he was a very very racist guy and so
this was another way to just point out
when he became president of all the
blacks that were served in the federal
government he took all that except one
he had his token black so he literally
was racist his history books were used
to create a Klan recruiting film well
before we get there go back up so so his
history books he was the President of
Princeton because the the president of a
university did this all Americans went
and said well this has to be the best
there is because it's really smart
that's a that's a big university right
he's a really smart guy so this became
the standard for all history books that
were done in America pretty much from
that time forward this has been the
foundation they based them on now from
these history books other things were
done which is where he was mentioning
the very first film ever showed in the
White House was actually called The
Birth of a Nation The Birth of a Nation
was a recruiting film for the KKK you
know the guy who did this said he based
it off of what he learned from the
history books of Woodrow Wilson about
how bad blacks were how good whites were
and whites have to save the day from the
evil blacks now what's interesting is he
kind of makes this association but he
says we're basing it off generally what
we've learned from these history books
so it all suspects of one giant appeal
to Authority fallacy he must know that's
right yes the Residential's he's an
alpinist and then it gets worse to see
he doesn't talk about black heroes but
he does mention blacks in American
history except the depiction he gives of
blacks in American history is quite
astounding that looks like the junk bond
lady in labyrinth that's that's his
depiction that's a natural look then and
this is so what we say is we're not
trying to be racist in saying this but
it looks like a monkey yeah right this
is his the picture is a very racist
depiction of it isn't incredibly racist
that's what [ __ ] when he talks about
blacks in his book that's what he does
even what's fascinating about this is
it's where where would Woodrow Wilson
get this idea and this is where even
studying his
you back up Charles Darwin in his book
Origin of Species the title is not
Origin a species period there's actually
more the title and the title says the
Origin of Species by means of natural
selection and can you read what it says
below it I don't want I don't want to
know no all right I have to don't it's
or the President or the preservation of
favoured races and the struggle for life
okay Darwin wrote that there were
different levels of races that were
struggling and actually exist an
original printing this is this is one of
the original books so what do you
actually argues in this book I can point
to four different places in this book
where he actually argues that the
lighter your skin the more evolved you
are right the darker your skin the less
evolved which so where did Woodrow
Wilson get his ideas this is what
Charles Darwin was advocating and
actually Darwin was not in favor of
slavery but he was very racist he said
we actually maybe you just send the
blacks back to Africa until they fully
evolved that you can't have much more
racist statement than that right but but
this is this is the price the reason why
is because it's not even a
socio-economic State no yeah it's not
even for example even we have
disagreements in the black community or
politically where people say well what
do we do to serve the black community
some people leave that's doing in pop
with poverty first people believe it's
dealing with gangs first it's not
predicated than that it's predicated
it's the sole premises they're less
evolved as kryolan tried beatrix that's
right what's the definition of attrition
that name from leading progressives at
the time I mean both the rest guys are
very much in because this is the view of
the guy who wrote the books that became
the standard for US history
well guess why we don't celebrate black
heroes because you can't celebrate black
heroes because there's no black heroes
we're celebrating is kind of the view of
Woodrow Wilson and because we know we
need some let's throw on MLK and let's
store some big names Frederick Douglass
and there's these others are all really
big names and those are those are modern
editions right those aren't I mean
Woodrow Wilson is not celebrating
Frederick Douglass right but but modern
writers go no there were some some
people we should celebrate but it still
is coming from a very faulty perspective
anybody like Woodrow Wilson does leave a
big fan club so I do think there are
some people that celebrate him in the
progressive circle but it's now you're
talking about people that celebrate
singer right you League of Nations the
UN I mean he's kind of the guy who found
became do they have any celebrate and
they say well we don't like that part
about Maggiore listen but sort of the
economic idea I'm not seeing anybody
make that separation though the
progresses at love and love him because
his internationalism and his thought of
big government and his thought of
controlled economies etc they love his
ideas but he's a little harder to sell
and so you gotta be careful cuz he is a
racist well but I think even saying that
we have the assumption that people
actually know things about it that's
right right right I mean generally it's
like you know FDR was a great president
why what did he do the New Deal right
well what did that do it was a new deal
right we don't know we've just heard
that somebody was good or bad and we
don't even know why right when we talk
about we do a lot with American history
we talk about George Washington okay so
if I said tell me a story about George
Washington most people would tell me
about George Washington chopping down a
cherry tree which is a fictitious story
that was written to talk about his
honesty and integrity the stories we
know never even happened and we just
don't know history well enough or that
he grew pot that's a big common man now
industrial area for something he did
wrong didn't grow industrial hemp talk
about though he was growing like smoking
wasn't going and smoking his joint on
the back porch right if he did not much
would happen for ships who smokes a ship
rope I mean it's I don't tamper a hand
in through your ship but you probably I
don't know ii the original hotbox
luminescence cuz we're talking about
this when we're talking about the Civil
War and I wanted to test them a little
bit more because some of the things that
people believe they know also aren't so
sure
for example the Southern Strategy right
because they know Abraham Lincoln
Republican that's supporting the price
place but at some point it's switched
and you were kind of going they always
points a Strom Thurmond yeah sure I'd
like you to kind of reiterate at that
point because I think it's something
that a lot of people miss yeah the the
thought that well the Republicans
dominates the South today but they're
the old Democrats they're the ones that
were the racist and they just got over
to the Republican Party get elected my
challenge to them is all right show me
ten examples of that because they can
always show me too
I've never had anybody go more than two
examples Strom Thurmond Strom Thurmond
and David Duke
and that's pretty much as far as it goes
well and really when you look at the
thousands of people since if we would go
back to the Civil War who is switched
you probably come up with a couple
hundred but now we're talking about out
of tens of thousands I see that's the
deal because every if we go back to the
60s and South one was called the solid
Democrat south or every two years you
have an election I'm gonna say there's
at least a thousand in Texas is there's
about 10,000 people elected every two
years because we have 254 counties about
27 people in each County right and you
have local school board's mayor City can
so we're going to say at a minimum
there's a thousand people every two year
election and you've got eleven southern
states part of the Confederacy so let's
say that at that point in time you have
eleven thousand people you can elect
every two years and we've been doing
this 50 years which is 25 elections so
now we're looking at quarter-million
people we've collected in South show me
a hundred show me 200 in that period of
time there were Democrats that I came to
Republicans that did not change their
philosophy now I've been with a lot of
Democrats who switched the Republican
Party one of the guys told me said I've
been a democratic party my whole life
we've never said the Pledge of
Allegiance I'm Republican meeting I
thought we should be saying that and you
guys opened with the prayer when I want
to be a Republican it was not about race
it was about different values and that's
often it is they often point to Strom
Thurmond sure what was the reason to him
becoming Republican was it because he
was a racist or he became a racist yeah
he was a segregationist and he was a
racist he had a change of heart and a
lot of guys did which actually even even
a change of heart some people point to
faith because they'd have a conversion
to Christianity at some point in his
life
yeah which was actually in that period
of where he's switching parties which
even becomes interesting because then
when he switches and becomes a
Republican who does he hire to work on
his staff yeah as a Republican he went
out and became the first southern
senator of any party to reach out and
start hiring blacks into high positions
in staff we're not talking secretarial
we're not talking answering phones we're
talking strategists on his staff and he
goes out and is the first southern
senator to do that he did that as a
Republican not as a Democrat a favor
change there was a lot of changes that
happen in him such a key detail in
context I think most people don't
understand it is became less racist
right he had a change of heart
well even as you phrased the question
right well more people talk about that
the great switch that happened
it becomes significant a lot of times as
conservatives or even as people of faith
as Christians we get put on defensive
and we have to defend what somebody else
accuses wait a second if if you're
making a claim the impetus does not mean
a prisoner that you're wrong I'm right
now you have the impetus to prove what
you're saying is right right and this is
where sometimes I think we're not as
strategic as we should be and say no
wait a second you're saying that okay
so who all switched I don't have to
prove they didn't switch you have to
prove they did switch right and this is
where they now have an insurmountable
mountain because they can't less than 2%
and I mean significantly less than 10%
ever switched of the tens of thousands
of people that were elected it's not
even close well and you say you go to
you go to schools or groups a lot and
teach kids about what it is you're quite
a bit what is it if you could kind of
teach one thing I guess to black
audience members right now or black
children bout black history that maybe
they're not learning sir what would you
like to I would say you want to learn
the good and the bad and the ugly
because that's a part of everybody's
history every nation's history you know
for us as Christians that's in the Bible
we get David good thing that he was a
king a good king bad thing they couldn't
keep any of his kids under control and
an ugly thing that he killed Uriah and
slept with Bathsheba Bible gives you
good bad ugly what we do in America
today we have a tendency to emphasize
the bad and the ugly note know very
little about the good so we will always
show overcoming blacks who had huge
oppression huge racism and that needs to
be shown that's part of the bad the ugly
we all agree but the good side is also
there we had a huge impact with black
Americans in so many areas and science
and and poetry and literature and in
military and in education great guys
that we don't even talk about and so
we've got a skewed perspective and what
you should know is that you teach the
good bad ugly and we do a great job by
teaching the bad and ugly the very poor
job they do it and there's a lot of
moments where there was a lot of unity
in America and so often with look at the
segregation and a vision the frustration
and that's part of it but but there was
a lot of really good moments that we
just don't know I was talking I'm at a
university I gave a speech afterwards I
the professor challenged me and was at
Princeton no I could have I gonna find
it there yet no but they said this
professor said how dare you say that
America is a special nation because
we've done more bad than we've ever done
good I said okay what's your example of
all the bad things he said well we had
slavery in America
winning of women's rights till the 20th
century I said okay interesting you pick
those two you know I said if your
standard that we're being bad you're
gonna start with slavery I said tell me
a nation in world history that never had
slaves right right and he couldn't I
said okay tell me a people group that
was never enslaved and never enslaved
somebody else and he could and I said
right slavery is a history of humanity
it's not just American history I said
but that's not even history it's the
present for a lot of countries well 40
million is slavery today we rights right
people enslave today than we had in
three hundred fifty years of this lay so
this is still embraced in many nations
but that's a really good point but what
I told them is can you name a nation
where white people actually fought white
people and then freed all the black
people right right because I only know
of one nation that had that kind of
civil war and it was America and I said
so even if you're saying like if we
agreed every nation as bad because
everyone in a nation had slavery I would
still contend America is one of the best
of the bad nations because we fought a
war to end slavery at a time when
slavery is still embraced in a lot of
places and I think a lot of people get
that wrong you know being raised in
Canada or they think that the United
States was late to the party and ending
slavery this will look at England people
don't understand that there's a very
different time limit in the United
States and the British Empire right
which had slavery long after correct the
civil well even if you said British
Empire ended at first we would be
probably the second although Mexico and
it's like so for when we asked a
question we're in its slavery before
America that becomes important because
people point to Wilbur over 40 and they
point to England although not all of the
Empire right ended slavery when England
did under Wilberforce which is kind of
important when you think of how the
Empire was supported yeah correct
that's make you miss a ha second we
don't have a long say what about what
about the rest of the empire right well
I had somebody point out in Mexico to me
one time well Mexico in its laid before
America dead and and that's where
understanding history becomes kind of
interesting because Mexico ended slavery
but they allowed indentured servitude
where you can indenture all your former
slaves for 99 years and pay them like a
peso yeah so so that you like
technically slavery another hundred
years but this is where we have these
faults and notions of America that
America did something nobody else did
and what's what I think is a
misconception in our history is that no
nation is perfect every nation is full
of people and and people are not perfect
right but what our nation's you need
that is every time there were moments
where we were doing terrible things
there was unique people standing up and
being a voice saying we've got to be
different and our nation corrected
course sooner than almost any other
nation in the history of these last
several hundred years and this is where
our nation's unique now that we have had
problems but that we've changed and
corrected those problems long before
anybody I stand I would point out one
other thing that that's not get pointed
out well when you look at the Civil War
we think that's an even split the North
versus South No 18% of the population is
seceded 82% stayed on the anti-slavery
side right so you had a very strong mind
to watch the Civil War video that we did
they all expressly wrote that it was
because of slavery that's why they
wanted to leave yeah that's right and
left in their secession documents they
said the reason we are leaving the Union
is slavery
that's all 11 states so that a that's
not to say that everybody was fought as
was already identified never that fought
was in favor that in fact there's
records of some people in Sanford and
they said well we fought because these
Union soldiers were in our land right so
that wasn't the idea of everybody but
all their leaders it was but it would
suggest that there was even a smaller
minority yes well these are whittling it
down a current really pretty small only
9% of America's own slaves at the time
the Civil War so you're you're talking a
small amount and we look at the nine
percent and would let that drive
everything and that's a bad nine percent
right but that's not the 91 percent and
that's what people don't look at and
that's the balance you have to happen
history you teach the good and the bad
and the ugly right that's a very good
way to look at it okay we appreciate for
people who've missed it that we have a
civil war we're gonna have a segment of
a Revolutionary War First Amendment
Second Amendment here with wall builders
David Barden and a mighty sorcerer Tim
subscribe these also patriotic Oh Ranger
panties are available at the shop that's
the only reason I'm wearing